I'm Katherine Kwan and I'm a developer
advocate at Google I started off by
working as an engineer on the Android
apps team I worked there for three years
on products like Google Play and Google
keep the note-taking app I'm continually
blown away by what you can build on this
platform and I'm particularly inspired
by those apps that can truly improve
people's lives
when I meet people they often tell me
about their great app ideas but then
they feel like they don't have the
technical skills to actually build it
that's why I shifted over to developer
relations so I could help people like
you really build something great
throughout this course I'll be helping
you implement your very first app my
name is Dan Galpin I've been a developer
advocate at Google for four years and
I've worn a lot of hats here my goal is
to keep us on track to make sunshine
something that had some resemblance to a
production quality app I'll introduce
Android design patterns and principles
many of which are often missed by new
Android developers you'll learn to lean
on the framework focusing on what makes
your app unique instead of reinventing
the wheel I'm reto Meier and I've been a
developer advocate for Android at Google
for five years I started working on
Android so long ago that back then there
were no devices all you had to work with
were an emulator a beader SDK and an
almost fanatical devotion to the
platform I'll be joining you from here
my underground Android developer bunker
and my goal isn't to get you up and
running as quickly as possible
is to teach you the context behind the
choices we'll make and the best
practices you need to really understand
how to create great experiences
specifically tailored to mobile devices
by the time you finish this course
you'll know more than just how to create
yet another app you'll know how to build
great apps that focus on the user